[Applause]
and finally new rule liberals need a
stand your ground law
for cancel culture so that when the woke
mob
comes after you for some ridiculous
offense you'll stand your ground
stop apologizing because i can't keep up
anymore with who's on the [ __ ] list
now lately republicans have been trying
to appropriate the term
cancel culture to describe what happens
to them
when they get a just comeuppance for
actual crimes
and this muddying the water is
unfortunate because canceled culture is
real
it's insane and it's growing
exponentially and it's coming to a
neighborhood near you
if you think it's just for celebrities
no
in an era where everyone is online
everyone is a public figure
it's like we're all trapped in the hills
have eyes and wi-fi
take mr emmanuel cafferty he is
was a san diego gas and electric worker
but he got fired because someone
reported him making a
white supremist hand gesture outside the
window of his truck
but he's not a white supremist he's
latino and he wasn't making a hand
gesture
he's probably just flicking a booger
is this really who we want to become a
society of phony
clenched [ __ ] avatars walking on
eggshells always looking over your
shoulder about getting ratted out for
something that
actually has nothing to do with your
character or morals
think about everything you've ever
texted emailed searched for
tweeted blogged or said in passing
or now even just witnessed someone had a
confederate flag in their dorm room in
1990 and you didn't
do anything
you laughed at a woody allen movie
andy warhol was wrong in the future
everyone will not experience 15 minutes
of fame but 15 minutes of shame
and 62 percent of americans say they
have opinions
they're afraid to share 80 percent
of americans young old rich
poor conservative liberal white
minority all hate the current atmosphere
of hypersensitivity
yeah everybody hates it and no one
stands up to it
because it's always the safe thing to
swallow what you really think
and just join the mob so if someone asks
you if
justin timberlake owes britney spears an
apology for not being a perfect
boyfriend when they were teenagers
just say yes easy
as justin did issuing an abject apology
and then
vowing to return sexy back to where he
found it
now you you may be asking why are we
even talking about this now well
the new york times did a documentary
about britney spears
really the new york times what do you
see the searing expose
they have coming up on pebbles
anyway in it we find out that teenage
justin hadn't become a perfect person
yet
and when asked if he had sex with the
girl whose big hit was called i'm a
slave for you
said yes what a cat although i truly
believe
any guy willing to wear matching outfits
can't be all bad
now as for a song called i'm a slave for
you
nothing no no is this some is this
something
the mandalorians gina carano is a person
i'd never heard of and resent that i
have now
she's some conservative wrestling chick
who kicks ass on a show i wouldn't watch
if i was in prison
and she made some nazi analogy who
doesn't these days
you're like the nazis is the new i don't
like you
it's always okay with trump the nazi
that disqualifies her for marching
around
planet who gives a [ __ ] in a helmet
by the way you can't work in hollywood
if you don't believe what we believe
yeah in the 50s that's exactly what the
left complained they were being told
now the week before it was chris
harrison's turn in the barrel
he's the host of the bachelor and is
stepping away
stepping away to educate himself on a
more profound and productive level than
ever before
oh good good
because all my life i've looked up to
the host of the [ __ ] a stranger show
and if i thought i couldn't count on the
bachelor for moral guidance i don't know
if i could go on
and of course he's not stepping away
because he's
the host of a televised snake pit where
32 female contestants are trapped in the
sorority house from hell
it's because he wouldn't throw one of
them under the bus
when it came to light that in college he
attended a
dress up like we're in the old south
party which is not a type of party
we should be throwing in that it winks
at a civilization built on slavery yes
but apparently in 2018 millions of
people were still doing it
and mature people understand humans are
continually evolving
as opposed to wokeville where they're
always shocked we didn't emerge
enlightened from the primordial ooze
what's chris harrison supposed to do
build a time machine go back to 2018 and
knock the mint juleps out of their hands
maybe while he's time traveling he can
have a word with that [ __ ]
abraham lincoln who's now canceled in
san francisco
and they're thinking about it in
illinois
yes the land of lincoln might cancel
lincoln
memo to social justice warriors when
what you're doing
sounds like an onion headline stop
you